I want to start with 2 things
first of all
many thanks to the old informer who pee here
for the positive and
constructive
the ways in which he led the conversations
thanks also to his staff
who was ready for us 24 hours a day
and for whom no question was too much
and thanks also to the bodes and the security guards in the
15 minutes formation
who gave us 1 warm welcome every day
who provided us with coffee and lunch
and he provided guidance
in and outside the formation fifteen minutes
tributes
and also thank you for being strong here
always had eyes and ear
for the people behind the police at the table
and acted on it
several times
and it hurts me a lot that the institute of
informer was not protected
secondly to the people in the Netherlands
I think it's terrible
that we were unable to complete the first phase
and that you are disappointed
bbb is going to do everything about it
to bring the formation to 1 successful conclusion
President democracy is not for frightened people
his minister polak ever in this room
and what i can say is
bbb
has never been afraid of verantwoordelijkheid to take
also for 1 young party like ours
cabinet partial names is 1 big step
but bbb is not afraid to make choices
not afraid to go live with big challenges
not afraid to stay at the table
bbb has always said that it is national interest
The main thing is that our country needs 1 new cabinet
those the big problems where with
citizens and farmers
have to deal with Want to go live
and like the rear tires of the p v
v v v v
v n
c and b b
b want to indicate time and time again in all investigations
and also at the formation table
we said this every time
every time the Netherlands yearns for 1 new cabinet
craves for 1 new course
yearns for solutions to the crisis in this country
that's where it must pass
the importance of citizens in the Netherlands
everywhere in the country where I go
people ask that of us farmers
entrepreneurs soldiers
nurse teachers
professionals and other citizens
piece by piece they ask for
1 government that brings renewal
1 government
who gets their children from the attic in their house
1 government that takes care of pensions
that pensions again 1 certainty
instead of becoming 1 roulette table
1 government that ensures that the energy is just in order
so that this country can continue to innovate
and the gas bill can be lowered at home
1 government that ensures migration
crisis is being tackled
and 1 government
which ensures that farmers can look at 1 pasture
instead of going to the porch of the provincial government office
the asphalt of the highway
or to the Grass on the maliefeld
and that fishermen can look at the sea again
instead of going to the
sroothopes of their cutters at camps chairman
the national interest stands
first and that must remain paramount
and that is why bbb has remained seated at the table
and we find it incomprehensible and still
not to contain
that this national interest is not paramount here
and on 6 February without informing us
walked away
to our question that afternoon if he would return
said omzicht here
I give you no guarantee
but chairman
in the meantime,
the Lord had already called the press
and the membership letter was already written
the Lord omzicht walked away on February 6 at 3 o'clock
the Lord wilders and frills silgus and myself
leaving behind waiting for clarity
and that clarity that came
exactly at 7 pm 1212 minutes past 7 in the evening
in the form of 1 message on the nos website
omzicht does not return
the media and the whole of the Netherlands knew it before we
are conversation parkers
and at 10 a.m.
in the evening we had to hear the explanation at oemberto
not sick 1 screw
I'd rather call this chairman
and sorry we haven't heard with the three of us yet
unfortunately after weeks of talking
weeks in which everything
but then everything was done
to give the Lord insight comfort
and that we could no longer be scheduled for conversations
that's right that wasn't possible either because the Lord's insight was gone
the voter spoke on November 22
and that is why bbb has remained seated at the table
we are not here for ourselves
we are here for the people in the Netherlands
the people who
have chosen us
the people who pay us
and the people who count on us
bbb did not run away before verantwoordelijkheid
that we have to the Netherlands
and will also in the next phase
this one verantwoordelijkheid want to take chairman
The Netherlands can't wait any longer thank you so much